poutine est en échec en europe y a pas
eu d'avancée particulière
il a essayé d'entamer un dialogue avec
la france avait été lui mais sans
vraiment de résultats et comme la russie
l'objectif c'est de de s'accroître tous
adultes n'y a jamais deux fois sur le
résident soit l'europe ce vraiment une
ambiance et on va dans tous les sens à
la fois qu'on est une puissance mondiale
une puissance pour finir à la fois
terrestre et maritime
effectivement il s'est beaucoup
rapproché de la chine peu à cause des
russes d'ailleurs et technologiquement
il a apporté beaucoup à la chine il a
apporté d'apporter beaucoup aussi
militairement à la chine c'est un appui
politique et diplomatique à la chine
pendant toutes ces années et maintenant
les états unis on a l'impression qu'ils
se réveillent et qui disent ah mince on
les a trop laissé faire
la russie effectivement sa puissance et
est de nouveau opérationnel ce n'était
plus qu'à pendant toutes les années 90
et finalement la russie apporter son
concours à l'émergence de la puissance
chinoise et donc il faut qu'on arrête ça
maintenant il faut que les états unis
bas parce qu'ils ont fait le diagnostic
ils ont compris ça je pense que bayonne
l'a bien compris
donc s'ils veulent effectivement c'est
pareil pas réussi et de lâcher afin
qu'ils mettent les moyens qu'ils mettent
qu'ils fassent des pas en avant des rc
ou qui ont demandé le sommet du g20
s'est passé pacotille dame au foot il
s'était très rapidement été très heureux
elle peut faire parce que il a à coeur
de montrer justement qui peut avoir un
dialogue en bilatéral avec les stats
musique est pas le cas toutes les
puissances au monde y compris en france
donc voilà je pense que maintenant
byron bay va falloir que pour attirer
les russies la flore qui donne du grain
à moudre
[Musique]